[Música]
buenas tardes
qué les parecería a ustedes si un día
tomándose un café con la responsable de
recursos humanos de su empresa les dice
uff
aquí no contratamos nunca gente de
murcia no no
gente de murcia no una vez contratamos a
uno nos fue fatal tuvimos una cantidad
de problemas después para despedirle que
no te imaginas
no espero que me contesten hay alguna
persona de murcia por aquí
nadie no lo puedo creer bueno no tengo
nada en contra de la gente de murcia por
supuesto me han tratado siempre
fenomenal y dirán porque les estoy
hablando de murcia bueno pues porque
este argumento de la responsable de
recursos humanos es el que se han
encontrado muchas veces nuestros
expertos en asesorar a las empresas
en la contratación de personas con
discapacidad lo único que tienen que
hacer es sustituir personas de murcia
por personas con discapacidad
claro imagina además da la casualidad de
que las personas con discapacidad que no
trabajan se aproxima en número bastante
a la población de la región de murcia
imagínense toda la población de la
región de murcia sin opciones de
trabajar esto me lleva a otra pregunta
qué haría la gente de murcia si
existiera ese prejuicio hacia ellos y
nadie les contratarse
por mi trabajo me enfrento en no pocas
ocasiones a una pregunta que siempre me
hace poner en tensión
me preguntan además como experta en
empleo y discapacidad porque llevo más
de 20 años trabajando en esto y podrían
decir pues ya te podías preparar una
respuesta después de 20 años
efectivamente tengo muchas respuestas
por cierto bastantes pero después de
pensar la pregunta por cierto es porque
las empresas no contratan a personas con
discapacidad
y después de pensar en esto para esta
charla y consultar con unos y con otros
no gente con la que tengo confianza pues
realmente creo que hay dos cosas dos
razones que son realmente las que nos
impiden avanzar en este en este tema no
son dos barreras invisibles que se
llaman bajas expectativas y miedo
lo bueno es que todos ustedes pueden
hacer cosas muy sencillas para superar
estas barreras invisibles y ayudarnos en
esta tarea colectiva de hacer una
sociedad más inclusiva voy a contarles
algunas anécdotas que creo que son las
que me hacen pensar como pienso sobre
este tema y que me han provocado
diferentes sentimientos a lo largo de mi
vida y reflexiones
y bueno pues la primera de ellas como
decía roberto tiene que ver con
con una película se acuerdan cuando se
estrenó et el extraterrestre 1982 hace
36 años yo me acuerdo mucho de esa
película porque cuando se estrenó
estábamos en las vacaciones de navidad
en valladolid efectivamente en una tarde
muy fría y húmeda de estas de valladolid
y mis hermanos y yo estábamos encantados
porque porque mi tío pepe nos había
invitado a ir al cine a verte fuimos al
cine al cine vista drama de valladolid y
cuando volvíamos a casa a casa de mi
abuela
pues escuché bajando del autobús un
comentario detrás de mí que se me quedó
grabado durante mucho tiempo era una
señora que le decía a otra pobres niños
tener que ir con ese hombre
y mi tío pepe
es un hombre con parálisis cerebral
tiene 40 y tenía 46 años entonces
y bueno pues tiene por su discapacidad
tiene algunas dificultades para moverse
de hecho me recordaba a mi madre que
hasta los 15 años no consiguió andar con
sus muletas
y puedes mantener conversaciones
maravillosas con él siempre que tengas
un poco de paciencia hasta que consigues
entender su forma de hablar de hecho en
el barrio donde vivía le conocían como
el alcalde del paseo zorrilla porque se
paraba a hablar con todo el mundo
bueno creció en una época en españa la
guerra y la posguerra en la que no tuvo
por supuesto servicios de atención
temprana ni otros apoyos que le hubieran
permitido estoy segura hoy día haber
podido estudiar una carrera
universitaria conseguir un trabajo y
seguramente incluso formar una familia
y es un gran luchador por supuesto con
gran sentido del humor como podría decir
de todas las personas con parálisis
cerebral que he tenido la suerte de
conocer a álvaro esther david
bien que significaba que el comentario
de aquella mujer en el autobús del que
me acuerdo después de tantos años pues
ni más ni menos las bajas expectativas
de que una persona con parálisis
cerebral como mi tío
pudiera llevar a sus hijos oa sus
sobrinos al cine como cualquier otra
persona es para bastante probable que
para aquella mujer una persona con
parálisis cerebral fuera más
extraterrestre que el propio t
bueno
también en valladolid en este caso el
año en el que se reunificaron las dos
alemanias 1990
nos acabábamos de mudar allí y un
familiar nos recomendó un oftalmólogo
para una primera cita y mi madre y yo
pues fuimos a esa revisión el
oftalmólogo era muy muy bueno me
hicieron la revisión rutinaria cuando
estaba sentada delante con mi madre
delante de su mesa me dice bueno sabina
todo está muy bien no tienes que cambiar
la graduación
ya sabes que tienes que intentar no
forzar la vista y hacer toda la vida al
aire libre que puedas
y yo le digo bueno pues eso va a ser un
poco difícil porque estoy estudiando y
me dice bueno y qué estudias y yo le
contesto pues estoy en cuarto de
económicas
saben lo que me contestó
me dijo hombre pues ya termina
puede parecer un comentario sin
importancia pero si lo piensan es
tremendo
y cuando me diagnosticaron con menos de
dos años mi déficit visual el médico que
me hubiese tratado hubiese sido ese
médico seguramente hubiera recomendado a
mis padres pues que no forzase la vista
que hiciera una vida tranquila y no
habría estudiado no habría tampoco
estudiado piano con las partituras sin
adaptar por cierto
y seguramente pues no estaría donde
estoy afortunadamente mi médico de niña
fue un gran médico de barcelona- del
hospital sant joan de déu el doctor
castany era que me recuerda muchas veces
la importancia de trabajar con vocación
esta baja expectativa en un profesional
médico para las personas con
discapacidad y en general para cualquier
persona es una de las cosas más
limitantes de hecho tiene consecuencias
que yo creo que son irrecuperables sobre
todo si se producen en la infancia y
debe hacernos pensar en la importancia
de no prejuzgar el potencial y las
capacidades de una persona
una de las primeras cosas que me tocó
hacer cuando llegué a fundación 11
fue implantar el sistema de gestión de
la calidad iso les suena esto bueno pues
ya cuando habíamos terminado todo el
proceso en la auditoría externa para la
certificación estábamos en una reunión
con el jefe de nuestro departamento de
informática jesús entonces que es una
persona ciega
y el auditor pidió unos datos que no
teníamos en ese momento mi compañero
jesús se levantó de la mesa se fue a su
ordenador tecleo unas cosas en el
ordenador y en dos segundos tres
segundos tuvimos en la impresora los
datos que necesitaba el auditor que los
dejó delante de la mesa bueno la cara de
aquel hombre era para haberla grabado
después de terminar la reunión les estoy
un rato curioseando con jesús como hacía
para utilizar su línea braille para
trabajar bueno el tío estaba alucinando
y
y esto es un ejemplo también de las
bajas expectativas en el ámbito laboral
[Música]
voy a contextualizar los un poco esta
situación 6 de cada 100 personas en
españa con en edad de trabajar son
personas con discapacidad 6 de cada 100
y sólo una de cada 4 trabaja
de los 21 5 millones de contratos que se
firmaron el año pasado en españa en 2017
solo el 1 43 por ciento fueron para
personas con discapacidad pero si
quitamos los contratos que firman
empresas sociales cuyo fin es crear
empleo para personas con discapacidad
ósea que ya están convencidos ese
porcentaje se queda en un 1 por ciento
es decir sólo 1 de cada 100 contratos es
para personas con discapacidad qué está
pasando aquí
pues claramente que para las personas
que toman las decisiones de contratar
los que contrata jce no tenéis a las
personas con discapacidad en vuestro
panorama de posibles candidatos por eso
son tan importantes las bajas
expectativas que tengamos sobre las
personas porque las decisiones de
contratar no las toma una empresa como
un ente las toman las personas y en
algunos casos incluso los responsables
de recursos humanos que tendrán que
convencer a otros para que contraten a
esa persona
bueno
sobre el miedo
no tengo muchas cosas que decirles sobre
el miedo todos ustedes habrán tenido que
enfrentar algún miedo alguna vez y saben
que la única solución es prepararse y
enfrentarse
sobre el medio tengo una anécdota que
puedo contar porque poco tiempo después
de suceder una eminencia como es el
doctor mario alonso puig me dio una
explicación racional yo soy bastante
racional y me quedé bastante tranquila
mi hija pequeña tenía un poco menos de
tres años entonces y estábamos en un
centro comercial
después de salir del probador me acerqué
al mostrador para pagar la compra y de
repente oigo a mi hija
bueno me giro y veo que se lo está
gritando a una mujer con síndrome de
dawn que estaba acompañada por otra
persona como se imaginarán el shock para
mí fue bestial no
y entonces nada la niña se llevó una
charla de estas que quedó completamente
neutralizada y no dijo ni una sola
palabra hasta llegar a casa
bien qué le pasa a nuestro cerebro
cuando tenemos miedo cuando nos
encontramos en una situación de medio de
miedo se pueden producir dos cosas o
atacar qué es lo que hizo mi hija o huir
bien llegamos al fin bueno por cierto
las empresas no diría yo que son
entornos muy propicios para que la gente
no tenga miedo verdad auditoría interna
auditoría externa mapa de riesgos
compliance penal ley de protección de
datos
ley de transparencia vamos que si eso no
da un poco de miedo díganme ustedes qué
es lo que es nuevo de ansiedad además de
mucho trabajo por cierto
bueno pues que puedo recomendarles yo
para en mi experiencia de todos estos
años de trabajar codo con codo con
personas con discapacidad para que
avancemos en esto de la contratación de
personas con discapacidad pues tengo
cuatro recomendaciones la primera no
huyan
no voy a la segunda inmunicen se contra
el miedo que pueden hacer para
inmunizarse contra el miedo pues pueden
hacer muchas cosas los más cómodos por
ejemplo pues ver películas charlas ted
por cierto hay bastante sobre
discapacidad yo les recomiendo por
ejemplo las de mi buena amiga edurne y
marta arte que eso es la mejor judoka
paralímpica también la de óscar
rodríguez también pueden
si quieren salir un poco más de su zona
de confort pues por ejemplo vayan a ver
competiciones de deporte de personas con
discapacidad partidos de baloncesto en
silla de ruedas o cualquier otro deporte
paralímpico yo cuando fui a ver la
primera competición de natación
paralímpica en en atenas-2004 fue una de
las de las experiencias más alucinantes
de mi vida la verdad
queremos puede que más les recomiendo
pues
[Música]
también pueden
y contagiar a otras personas hablar con
normalidad sobre la discapacidad con
otras personas en el ámbito por ejemplo
familiar pues utilicen un recurso que
tenemos en la fundación 11 que se llama
biblioteca infantil cuentos que
contagian ilusión son 11 títulos en los
que los personajes son niños y niñas con
distintas discapacidades en la empresa
pues cuenten con los trainers
paralímpicos deportistas de alto nivel
que han competido a alto nivel y que les
pueden explicar desde los valores del
deporte y la discapacidad como los
límites realmente nos los ponemos
nosotros también pueden pedirnos venir a
visitar empresas sociales como las del
grupo social 11 donde pueden ver a mucha
gente con discapacidad trabajando y como
como pueden a través de ayudas técnicas
u otras medidas no pues poder trabajar
de manera en un entorno completamente
empresarial normalizado
y por último si se quieren comprometer
más déjense aconsejar
la fundación 11 ayudamos a las empresas
a abordar este compromiso de hacer una
sociedad más inclusiva y más diversa y
una empresas más diversas esto es muy
importante cuando pensaba cómo concluir
esta charla
pensé que me hace a mí diferente de
otras personas de algunos de ustedes a
la hora de pensar sobre este tema de la
discapacidad pues haber tenido la
fortuna de a lo largo de mi vida tener
personas con discapacidad a mi alrededor
trabajar rodeada de personas con
discapacidad y
y esto es lo que me hace diferente
realmente y para terminar quiero
hacerles un regalo les voy a leer un
texto que se escribió hace 216 años
y que dice lo siguiente
o hombres cuando algún día leáis estas
palabras pensar que habéis sido injustos
conmigo
y dejad que se consuele el desventurado
al descubrir que hubo alguien semejante
a él que a pesar de todos los obstáculos
de la naturaleza igualmente hizo todo lo
que estuvo en sus manos para ser
aceptado en la superior categoría de los
artistas y los hombres dignos
este texto lo escribió beethoven se
acordarán que les dije que estudie piano
y en mi casa en el piano y utilice que
utilizábamos para practicar mis hermanos
y yo había bueno todavía está un retrato
de beethoven que seguro que es
reconocible para ustedes es en el que
aparece con el pelo alborotado y un
gesto muy malhumorado y seguramente
ustedes también saben que beethoven
estuvo a punto de bueno se quedó
prácticamente sordo
lo que no sé si saben es que algunas de
sus obras más magníficas les escribió ya
siendo les digo prácticamente sordo y
después de haber estado al borde del
suicidio por la desesperación que le
causaba el perder la audición me regaló
entonces es para que cuando lleguen a
casa busquen en internet la sonata
número 30 para piano y la escuchen puede
ser hoy puede ser otro cualquier otro
día por supuesto se acuerden de lo que
les he contado y piensen que esa música
maravillosa la escribió una persona que
carecía prácticamente el sentido de la
audición
y muchas gracias por escucharme
[Aplausos]